هلا هلا هلا هلا
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم وضعت قطر خطه لاجل الملاعب
المونديال التي تختلف مصائرها بعد نهايه
البطوله التاريخيه لمونديال 20 22 الاكبر
في البطوله ستعمل قطر على تحويله لمجمع
فيه العديد من المدارس والمساكن والمحل
والعيادات الطبيه مع تحويل مرافقه لخدمه
مدينه لوسيل الجديده مع الحفاظ على شكله
الخارجي ليبقى كتفكار لهذا الموسم
رياضي للمنتخب الوطني القطري للسيدات
استاذ استاذ النصر
الا 32,000 مقعد وتبرع بالمقاعد المفكره
استاذ خليفه الدولي سيبقى على هذه كمقر
لاكاديميه ومجمع للالعاب المائيه مقر
لمشفى للطب الرياضي اما الساعه 974 هو
المصنوع من حاويات قابله لتفكيك سيتم
تفكيكه بالكامل والتبرع به لاحدى الدول
الناميه لدعم رياضه للي تحبه خلك قربه
وجنبه اللحظه لك الان ما هي والله صعبه
[موسيقى]